intervient car de l'eau rtement la
servier pourquoi à la serviette va jouer
un grand rôle dans la dégustation de
l'auto là et encore y en a qui sont bien
plus fortement pour les déguster ça j'en
suis sûr parce que moi j'en mange pas
assez souvent quand même mais la
serviette sert à cacher lorsqu'on a
l'ortolan dans la bouche parce qu'on a
la bouche pleine de grèce et au retour
l'arrêt très gras alors on a tout la
grèce qui dégouline dans la bouche
et puis derrière la serviette on peut se
concentrer davantage on peut se régaler
apprécié déguster vraiment voir ce qu'on
a dans la bouche c'est une chose qu'on
ne peut pas avoir souvent et on va en
profiter au maximum
voilà alors là je vais commencer à
marcher mon art hogan
alors je le prends et c'est tortola îles
et brûlant n'est ce pas alors je le mets
et voyez-vous contre la joue elle échoue
je ne souffle pas et parce qu'il
pourquoi un soufflet pour l'attendre et
on est là ça y est envoyé j'éprouve je
commence déjà à voir de la grèce faire
la figure c'est ça qui est pas joli
alors non je n'ai mendois se mettant
déguster
ces chants puis la chose qu'on ne
devrait pas refaire et qui n'est pas
très joli je commence à le prendre
l uçk us ces dernières au monde à mercy
huit buts et ce que j'aime a rejoint
d'importants chaud
c'est bon vous dire que je vous ai
construit à ma place je vous assure si
vous pouviez avoir ce que moi j'ai je
suis que renta je suis sûr de berger
sera devant vous mais mes vraies marges
je suis avez vous de tout coeur est avec
vous régalez vous avec moi en même temps
que c'est bon
vous assurez absolument à tous les vents
ma tête c'est c'est pas comparable à
rien mais je vous assure
le plan c peut être soumis nièvre ce
griot minier capam hamouri pourra mourir
d'une coop que se racontent elles
surprise de maïté mishin pour ceux qui
n'ont pas trop de temps finalement entre
midi et deux pour manger un petit encas
comme consistant
alors vous allez avoir droit à une
recette exceptionnelle et un 10 minutes
une recette que vous ne trouverez dans
aucun livre de cuisine ça vous promet
maintenant que vous ne verrez pas faire
ce moment que vous ne mangerez peut-être
pas très souvent donc plus et bien je
vais faire un hamburger rio parce qu'on
du valais qui s'invite à riom tout à
fait enfin comme on fait son match et
vous voilà à meetic au footing pour
faire barrage aux pas grand chose un
petit pain de campagne en moyenne il ya
plus gros voilà comme couvre en deux
mais voilà la jolie c'est ce qu'il faut
après là dessus j'y mets quelques
petites feuilles de salade de gésiers
des lamaneurs magret et du foie gras
chaud et on referme le couvercle et en
mange ça c'est mon père qui prouve la
belle santé des ombres exactement alors
montrez nous c'est de faire venir ben
foie gras mais malgré les gésiers avant
qu'on avait installé sur la jolie salade
ça va de soi réponse de sa maman alors
vous
une demi seconde étape à bien ses parts
on n'aide pas les gars parce que c'est
bon ça nourrit un nourrisson longue
les quatre jeunes agressés pas difficile
à jouer mais je suis encore là voilà on
va dire que ce soit nourri sa non et ça
c'est pas mauvais voilà anti mollahs et
un petit couvercle par là dessus non
j'ai tout donné au petit déjeuner à
pierrot tous les jours n'importe où sur
son travail
oui c'est bon maintenant vous savez je
vous ai apporté suite bordeaux que cette
viande élevée vous aussi vous aurez le
choix maintenant on est en cours de
classique traditionnelle le modèle du
genre de riez pas tranquille serein de
vanité de riom et l'emporter périmés
réponse parce que votre soirée pour sept
centièmes de la cuisine des
mousquetaires
nous avons ri nous rions souvent mais
vous avez vu de qualité comme faisant la
cuisine très très bien elle rit mais là
c'est bien on vous en fait autant et
puis on sera toujours heureux de vous
retrouver pour d'autres émissions que
j'espère vont continuer longtemps en
dialogue avec vous bonsoir
à bientôt bonsoir
alors elles sont vivantes là vous croyez
oui pour le moment elles dorment bien
gentiment est scellé avançant dans les
cheptels à vous croire ces eaux là parce
que qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir faire
eh bien il va falloir les assommer et
les tuer il entendu voilà alors fait
pour les tuer je veux être assommé on va
voir l'autre mais il faut les 1,6 et
d'un taux de tours voilà il faut
l'exercice écoulé tout bouge pas ma
chérie ne bouge pas ma chérie on ajuste
ses liens et à prix on l'appelle aïe aïe
aïe oui oui oui allez le viêt-nam a plus
rien à ma puisse alors là j'ai pas mal
chiffres oui vous allez voir et la peur
et micheline la voile bas parce que vous
lui avez raconté évidemment à la voile
et bien vous allez voir on va pas
s'offrir comme ça y'a plus rien à ma vie
vient là là il faut pas être un grain de
tenue et et oui et c'est dix ans il
tient votre chiffre à peu près au cas où
vous la somme est un petit coup la
programm
je crois que ça ne lui suffit même pas
tu n'auras pas ma peau a dit moi c'est
vigousse l'entêté la terrible
vous avez l'air de vouloir dormir et
c'est rien ça y est voilà
eh bien là c'est vous qui allez me
prendra la relève oui je la connais bien
m'a serré oui et moi je vais prendre le
couteau voilà on va tourner comme ça il
va faire tout le tour
et après ça vous rappeler ça va être
très difficile mais on va y arriver
c'est arrivé à turin pelé et a
facilement la mort je prendre aussi fort
oui oui jouer comme ça la tête va
peut-être vous of nantais témoin
d'accord avec le chiffon dragon dessous
ça y est je la tiens mais il faut faire
la prise était très facile mais pas du
tout et il est facile mais je savais que
dans les cavités pas f
allez y allez allez allez allez oliver a
dit sa villa
voulait pas d'un petit coup de couteau à
les méchins
ça veut dire ça vient ça vient à
l'esprit est là je voudrais fort là
parfait magnifique huit nageuses de mort
à la mi saison on a eu en fait
maintenant nous allons chez moi rue
houdon agirait en fait pas ça tous les
jours il faut que damir aller ça y est
je vous débarque tout ça mais qu'est ce
que vous allez faire maintenant et bien
maintenant on va là pour sonner sa
cavale dire et on va faire notre
maintenant bon alors première opération
l'a tronçonné consommer et va lui couper
la tête tout à faire la voile après la
coupe un morceau la revoilà ma belle il
ne reverra plus voilà et puis ensuite
dans la vie draps bien entendu oui et
puis regardez si les frais ouais c'est
superbe
vous l'aviez simplement pas son doigt de
lyon sur que oui et s'attire les gars
vous êtes débarrassé de votre chiffre
est mort bien sûr merci machine c'est
bien voilà très bien de ce nom ne vend
pas n'est pas là il est là c'est
enfantin comme je dis tu souffres oui
enfin c'est plus facile de faire bifteck
vous est cher par résultat est tellement
bon qu'une fois de temps en temps on
veut se donner la peine de faire ce
genre de choses et vous serez sans doute
un atout mais on a très très bien vu
comme vous le faites
voyez-vous nelson cette étude culinaire
que vous avez été faire en france était
très importante à nos yeux nous avions
besoin de savoir comment la cuisine
française était perçu par un anglais
alors un show votre premier commentaire
je dois dire romain ailleurs julien que
compte tenu de tout ce que l'on dit sur
la cuisine chez nous vous pensez bien
que ce voyage d'étude des très très
grande importance à mes yeux le rendez
vous avec les françaises c'est française
qui monte et pathé dans tous les sens du
mot et notamment dans celui de leur
capacité à parler les langues étrangères
et chattes que je me présente un 8eme
dire mes guides qu'avec mon mari est
longue et qu'il ya une vrai que beaucoup
voient là acquis à monza guetta et kelly
white hat
ça veut dire on lie à revers et un vrai
que là et peu glorieux affichage à
toutes et à tous ma merde
nelson je vous connais que trop votre
sérieux certes à la rédaction de cette
thèse sur l'art culinaire français mais
les françaises ont bien dû vous
enseignez d'autres choses
je dois dire qu'elles sont parfaitement
à la hauteur de leur réputation
j ai trouvé chez elle magie poésie amour
humour il ya du haut de l'ère du las
martinés du shakespeare réunis c'était
une très belle expérience
tu l'as entendu l'amour de domaine de
seconde la torah de nuit
non non pour avoir appliqué et 10 passes
un premier toit et moi je passais un
dernier jeu donnait une tisane il va
dormir j'ai pris la pilule dans ce soir
et tout ce monde et la merde et moi je
suis prudente et régis bonjour on
voulait à mon argent maintenant je fais
attention je souhaitais gorge mais blanc
ou couleur chair alors il a combien de
poule est alors au tour de l'île avant
ça car il en a une ou deux compères ils
veulent avoir plus même
mais afin de donner du plaisir à une
trentaine d pouze vers me l'ont pas dit
personnellement mais je pense que oui
pas mal dans la des femmes c'est pas mal
je remarque des femmes les animaux
étaient plus vigoureux clé il faut bien
dire je vous la conseille parce que sous
les narines c'est vraiment ça me qu'est
ce que vous ne pensez même c'est
excellent et ça sent très bon et puis ce
goût d'un il a peu à peu les faire
l'amour mais après ça bien à salade
exigeant nous n'aurons pas le temps de
faire aujourd'hui les choux aux
escargots pour une prochaine fois
alors au revoir et à bientôt à des
chattes mais c'est sa vessie et qui si
glen hütthaler là c'est pourquoi il faut
jamais me dire mon agent ne m'a chanté
deux chansons quand il faut pas tant les
parler d'amour après la purée d'ail là
c'est foutu maintenant je suis tout à
fait ce qui est le mieux
nelson
on connaît le raffinement des françaises
quand il s'agit de faire de la cuisine
mais dans l'intimité
j'étais justement en train d'y rêver
dans l'intimité tout n'est que douceur
tendresse caresse générosité surtout
surtout une infinie douceur ou maïté là
vous me racontez des histoires
il ya des oeufs aux as mais je n'en veux
pas je sais les clés du compte ce n'est
pas neuf
vous êtes sur certaines qu'est ce que
c'est les claques si coco et c'est les
couilles
bon je crois que je comprends ce que
voulait dire un document commun qu'est
ce que vous n'aimez dise ce que vous
venez de me diront j'ai tout vu à
l'extérieur je comprends pas ce que
voulait me revoir et la lisant à
l'intérieur bon tout le monde a compris
c'est pas des se saborde l'intérieur je
savais que ça en fait quand même des
jolies poulet
comment dirais-je j'ai toujours lu ou
entendu que la cuisine était révélatrice
de troubles psychologiques notamment
dans la façon de faire les plats vous
avez noté des choses similaires troubles
dites vous ce que j'ai en tout cas
constater c'est que les françaises
semblaient véritablement avoir la
cuisine ancré au fond d'elle-même et à
travers leurs plats ma foi il n'est pas
surprenant que certains éléments
historiques ressurgissent un exemple
précis pour être tout à fait précis je
dirais que les françaises font peut-être
tout simplement le complexe de jeanne
d'arc
on va la flambée avec la fine champagne
ça y est ça beau nous regarder
voilà ça peut pas être mauvais vous avez
cependant et maintenant je vais sortir
les morceaux dans bleu oui voilà mon
blazer c'est l'armagnac à edimbourg
j'imagine que c'est parce que vous allez
le flanc mais je vais flamber les
bordeaux voilà il faut pas les mettre là
et ça va finir de les dresser un petit
peu on va leur donner à manger du
vialenc regarder ça voilà vous délicieux
bien sûr très bien et alors ensuite une
fois on avait dit pas tout à fait cuire
va tout donner quelques il va falloir
faire alors je vais les mettre dans ma
sauce j'ai mis mon pastis à chauffage
chauffer alors là là un petit coup de
feu un petit coup de pompe à l'armagnac
ici pour sa flamme
oui voilà
sa femme doit la mise au pas de course
font l'écho fort
et ce à l'aide à cuire
elle sonne revenons quelques instants
quand même sur votre sur votre voyage en
france sur ce voyage scientifique ce
voyage culinaire avez vous remarqué ô
combien les français sont attachés à
notre patrimoine les grands noms de la
cuisine française ça compte à des grands
noms les grands chefs vous l'avez dit
absolument il ya là un véritable
héritage un respect permanent
ces grands chefs qu'elle n'hésite pas à
citer le plus souvent appris que vous
n'entendez dans la recette de beaux culs
celui-là il ajoute le porte au madère où
le vin blanc ou deux c'est quoi tout à
fait à la fin quand ça a été passé il ne
fait pas dire avec et il s'appelle
refuse alors non envahissant la pelouse
vaucluse à ce que vous en rappelez pas
vous tromper les poivrons de trois
couleurs ça fait rare d'en voir des
journées jean louis mary c'est plus joli
et puis c'est bon c'est assez bon quand
vous les rouges et les verts c'est plus
banal thomas ce qu'est ce que vous en
avez fait quoi là lâche les mondes et ça
fait dix ans que j'ai coupé en petits
morceaux et avons très bien que ce soit
la rue ou dans les ligues de cuisine on
en croit du vocabulaire et williams hank
est pas toujours le merveilleux qui me
va pas du tout allez moi je crois que là
c'est chaud non même et nous mettre dans
l'assiette
non on a bien des froides mais non parce
que c'est ça vous sur les bords mais
mettez les devoirs jeu dans le ter non
mais on va pas le manger on va le
montrer c'est le 1er août et que c'est
chaud oui
les choux 7 jan on ne lui a jamais été
comment voulez vous que je vois 2008 ce
n'est gd910 est dans l'eau bon alors
vous êtes petite magicienne et vous
savez voir comme ça si c'est que moi je
vous dis le voilà à vous essayez là
allez c'est bon vous dire qu'il est très
fort et gagner un peu de tarbes reçoit
s'en sortir là sur glace et lille vue
pour moi il vaut mieux jouer un jour et
par sens évident que vous ça vraiment on
dira que c'est enfantin et vous savez
j'ai essayé c'est pas si facile que ça
finalement
surtout là pour trouver le
l'articulation si marié vous allez dans
ses réserves et ne vous impressionner
par une mémoire à sa tête et que ça fait
plaisir et se faire voir
envoye sonné par les gangs voilà et
voilà ces marchés je vous ai porté
malchance je suis pas fâché parce que ça
m'est arrivé souvent
c'est pas facile aulas il repart écouter
beaucoup parce que tous leurs lots sont
emmerdés
et là je tout ça il y en a qui croient
qu'on s'amuse et où il est sec le corner
le micro il va prendre un chouia l'aïe
de ses mains oui surtout si ça je suis
un peu déconcentré ou pire arrive enfin
nelson permettez-moi de m'interroger ça
n'a pas dû être facile quand même ce
voyage culinaire barrière de culture
barrière de langue comment avez vous pu
appréhender toutes ces techniques
culinaires
ce qui se conçoit bien s'énonce
clairement et les mots pour le dire
arrivent aisément
j'ai retrouvé chez les françaises
un véritable amoureux des termes de
cuisine et des explications parfaitement
clair voilà mesdames mesdemoiselles et
messieurs le muy bien enfermée là je
vais mettre un petit peu de froid mais
parce que oh là là ça aurait claqué sort
éclaté alors bon là ça va pareil mais
pour nous pour vous pour nous c'est la
poule
oui enfin je m'explique pour nous ça ne
va parler pour vous c'est beau parce
qu'on vous a mis dans ce pot pour vous
montrer pouvait t impôt un peu plus gras
et vous le coup vrai et vous laissez
bouillir 2 heures mais comme un os était
trop important pour un pot alors on a
mis comme ça que vous avez tous compris
qu'il ferait pas ça comme ça voilà alors
vous remplissez d'eau y ait de l'eau à
ras bord et vous les fait bouillir 2
heures de retard
de ce côté là c'est la daube
c'est là dans le rouge alors c'est
beaucoup plus foncée oui et les carottes
fanes de carottes et le goût était plus
épicée plus fort c'est pas pareil ça
s'est fait presque pareil mais c'est
tout à fait différent on a des coquilles
saint-jacques toute fraîche toute belle
nous avons des tomates
nous avons des pas lourds bain des
belles huîtres a pris hier des charlots
toujours pareil du thym et du laurier du
persil ne laisse pas de lui du vinaigre
et sabine entendu des coques des petits
crabes et voilà c'est très bien sauf que
moi je savais pas que ça c'était des
huîtres maïté moi j'appelle ça plutôt
des moules en jeu du 18 trous et oui
c'est un grand faim qu'est ce que vous
croyez moi commence
mais voilà erreur de la lourde 1 n'est
pas hébergé qu'il faut recommencer alors
on commence il faut deux blancs d'oeuf
par kg de sel et à votre avis pour un
poulet gros comme ça il faudra combien
de rigolo quand nous alors là c'est à
dire les voilà non 4 kg de sun mais là
ça fait beaucoup quand même
ça fait beaucoup mais vous allez voir
les défauts alors maintenant les jeunes
voulaient je sortais je les mets de côté
et j'en ferai de la carangue l'aise elle
vient sur en eux je peux rire et nous
croyait que c'était mort
c'est l'un contre auquel et coquelles et
qu'on lui dire bon si vous savez pas
écouter ce que ces moments je sais dont
celle a vécu des mois c'est les poissons
des poissons fait de la merde ça les
réseaux non je crois que ce sont des
religieux il faudra passer de la famille
de la pieuvre on va dire oui voulait
qu'on le dit alors on dévoie céphalopode
céphalopode avait vendu parce qu'elle a
pris la paix par coeur des foires un
joli non non non bonjour bonjour
mais qu'est ce que nous avons devant
nous sont curieux animaux là n'est ce
pas c'est la famille de la pieuvre a
très bien mais sur cd comprenant 10 est
pas tout à fait des mollusques cd
comment ce qu on appelle ça du fado
exactement ça bon très bien les
céphalées quelque chose si les radios -
nelson vous avez eu accès à des endroits
privilégiés comme les cuisines des
grands restaurants
comment ça se passe entre les membres du
personnel en cuisine la principale
conclusion de ma tasse mahdia julien
c'est que une fois que la recette est
donné le consensus est totale
tout le monde est d'accord et bien
méritée après ce homard du pays bas
accompagné de six pommes de terre
persillées facile il me reste un peu tôt
peut-être pour faire une autre recette
oui
un autre marin en tenant une araignée
non je crois qu'on va faire d'abord un
homard aux herbes
bonjour bonjour
maïté quel est le menu du jour ne me
rappelle plus la brandade et la voirie
du pays à l'abri du pays basque à
s'allier trois minutes au four et
ensuite maïté est-ce que vous avez
encore une autre recette de mots bien
sûr on va faire la mouclade donna au
maire de chercher le nom de dieu non un
plat pour des amoureux sur la plage le
sel le poivre
les herbes qu'on a coupé très bien vous
voulez je vous prépare les yeux je
voulais simplement vous les verrez vos
herbes
voilà je mets en nous expliquant bien ce
que vous mettez jeu mais tout ça c'est
le persil ça c'est la ciboulette
ça c'est bien ça c'est l'échalote le
persil et là il tout ça je suis désolé
mais il faut couper parce que les jeux
ne sont pas durs ils sont mous on est
seul on alors ça je ne sais pas comment
vous voulez que je fasse avec ça et nous
avons un problème sérieux
mais nelson la grande cuisine à longueur
de journée les saveurs les odeurs savez
vous travaillez un petit peu à force je
dois dire qu'il m'arrivait d'en rêver la
nuit imaginez-vous seulement ses
senteurs comme vous le dites si unis que
si miraculeuse en rêver la nuit c'est
vrai
malheureusement ce n'était qu'un rêve
oh
nelson inverse et heures carnage je
commençais à avoir une petite soif et à
moi nelson la cuisine française
n'est-elle pas paradoxal n'existe-t-il
pas un paradoxe entre la façon de
préparer la recette est le plat final
c'est une très bonne question et je dois
vous dire que j'ai été un petit peu déçu
je m'attendais à ce que les choses
bougent davantage dans cette cuisine
j'ai trouvé l'atmosphère un petit peu
éteinte
bonjour bonjour c'est passé vite à la
marque
pour faire vite là qu'est ce qui s'est
passé donc son mandat et merde regarder
les jolies d'arnicourt a évoqué la
réception mais sur le seul modèle à une
poupée le plateau c'est ça ou c'est
plutôt dangereux me dis que je croyais
parfois on se régale et conviction
les juges sont bons alors nous verrons
on va voir quelle recette on va faire
avec du boeuf de chalosse bien entendu
non plus laisser la place et c'est moi
je vais pas pleurer
voilà un jouet temps rend le mans petit
il ya peut-être quelque chose que vous
avez remarqué nelson sais c'est le
respect du cuisinier face à l'animal
respect du cuisinier face à l'animal et
peut-être aussi l' inverse j'ai surtout
en fait remarquer linverse sa part est
peut-être un peu bizarre mais lorsqu'un
animal c'est qu'il va être cuisinée par
ces augustes main il semble être tout
d'un coup victime d'une dévotion totale
parra et respect tout simplement une
croix devant ils acceptent de la
décision la poule hermes a expliqué dans
le sud-ouest pour qu'il soit bon il faut
qu'ils aient couru en libye mais qui
fuit les quelque chose devant exactement
voilà ses courses à rien alors celui là
nous avons je ne voulais qu'ils viennent
à côté de chez vous tous vivent bien sûr
tous vivants il est très simple il est
comme les chats canton les grappes de
couronnes
le pauvre est alors pour l'accommoder il
faudra quoi
c'est merveilleux la vie est belle la
vie est belle de belles toujours mais en
réalité 100 milliards mais les touches
la x edward grey ma biche biche oh ma
biche comme tu glisses fais moi voir tes
jours lisent ils s'amusent comme des
fous prenez votre temps là où l'on
s'amuse ce sont des gambas vous avez dit
on alors j'ai fait le saut de l'espère
de l'aviron oui elles sont pas
méditerranéenne élevés en liberté ces
cousines germaines alors qu'il va
falloir faire maintenant bon alors
maintenant il faut les tuer bien large
regardez cette belle mort qu'ils ont eux
mêmes oui c'est cela ma chérie voilà un
bon alors annoncé pendant sept ans je
vais faire cuire des légumes vous a émis
dans quoi vous avoir manière à ça c'est
con mais je ris gratis vous demande
pardon sergueï est un hymne aux romains
sérieuse d'intérêt remet ça et c'est
démago la regarder ça et ça leur a donné
à son sous le feu des garçons sa lampe
être sous allait profiter
profitez de la vie bresse les enfants
producteur de leur ivresse ali voyez
tout mais après si oui et oui c'est
beaucoup voilà regardez ça c'est beau
regarder l'autre c'est beau la coupe à
la fin du dernier set elle a cassé la
hannon 2,7 et marjo et n'importe quoi et
mon petit j'ai fait mal
lucho vous êtes bêtes alors que vous
êtes bête avec vous êtes bêtes bombay
qu'est ce que tu as fait vos petits y
sommes avant peut-être six secondes
maximum en avril à nantes comme perdant
barjots mecheri et de deux parties même
avec ces petites choses comme ça ça peut
penser très fort ce probable oui bon ben
voilà c'est la lie de son parti doit la
barrière
là alors on va mettre ce matin et puis
un prometteur je vais mettre des légumes
au a déposé voulait que vous par un peu
de carreaux oui dès qu'un rien ne vous
arrêtera pts et d'autre de mourir dans
le poivre alors ça c'était pas payer
autant pour moi c'est un peu d'ordre là
là là là je n'étais pas dans la merde
dans la boue eh bien il va falloir les a
sauvés et les tuer il entendu voilà en
orbite pour les tuer
je vais perdre à sauver on va voir
l'auto mais il faut les 1,6 et d'un taux
de tours voilà il faut l'exercice écoulé
tout bouge par la chérie ne bouge pas ma
chérie enregistre ses liens et à prix on
l'appelle aïe aïe aïe oui oui oui
allez hop au viêt-nam a plus rien à ma
puce alors là j'ai pas de chiffres oui
vous allez voir c'est la peur et
micheline ça y est pas peur mais voilà
après ce que vous lui avez raconté
évidemment le voilà et bien vous allez
voir il va pas souffrir comme ça
y'en a plus rien à ma vie vient là là il
faut pas être un grain de tenue et oui
et c'est glissant il tient votre chiffre
à peu près au que oui oula ça met un
petit coup la programm
je crois que ça ne lui suffit même pas à
ma chérie tu n'auras pas ma peau mais
dites moi c'est vigousse non c'est pas
terrible
vous avez l'air de vouloir dormir et ça
y est
qu'est ce qu'il ya
les pinots mélanie elle est restée les
membres de carmen et alors ça fait rien
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas faire pour
gagner sa croûte
c'est pas vrai on va le couper en
tranches très bien il est vivant oh la
la
elles seront permettez moi d bassement
matérialiste mais ce voyage en france a
dû vous coûter une petite fortune
où avez vous trouvé leur joie feuille de
temps que nous autres britanniques ne
sommes pas connus pour être
particulièrement généreux de nos deniers
non je ne suis pas parti tout seul comme
ça avec mon propre portefeuille
je suis partie grâce au soutien fidèle
d'un partenaire d'un sponsor d'ailleurs
je lui ai promis un petit passage dans
notre émission alors si vous lui
permettez
pour le coc coleman en accord avec les
disques rionnais présente la compilation
laser des meilleurs titres de michael
l'arinella les petites marionnettes de
marionnettes à a doucement au poche
cherche à comprendre que c'est triste
venise que c'est faux
mais c'est vrai ya le poulet fumé un
corps l'aïe je vois une église au fond
d'imbroglio en ramant où le vin clocher
se mire dans l'eau
et bien sûr la dacquoise la compilation
laser regroupant les meilleurs titres de
maïté avec rio production c'est une
production par google mind
on aime les défis
mais dans les prés fleuris
l ol et paris on a le moral et mason
vous aurez certainement remarqué le
raffinement des cuisines français cette
façon de parler ce service sera finement
oui j'avais remarqué mais je n'en serai
pas fiers du tout à votre place pourquoi
ça je trouve que le langage des grands
chefs échappe complètement aux gens de
la rue aux gens de la rue de tous les
jours c'est un langage qui s'adresse à
l'élite intellectuelle de votre pays qui
échappe au plus grand nombre
en plus c'est un langage que j'ai trouvé
de toute façon beaucoup trop sophistiqué
et beaucoup trop raffiné annaba est
reparti mon kiki
non pas que les jeux ne sont pas des
marraines se croient pas il en manque
toujours de rue mais bon la bonne
bonjour bonjour
maïté qu'est ce que vous allez nous
faire aujourd'hui de la morue est alors
comment est ce que vous allez nous l'a
connu à l'accommoder parce qu'elle est
remportée de morue et bien ça j'ai pas
vu ce thème en lançant son appel
c'est bon jeu mais comme ça
m collet pour le restant de vos jours
bon il est frais ou ton père si non
c'est bon parce que dans le coup et
c'est bon tu parles belle bête qu'est ce
que vous avez l'intention d'en faire bon
et bien on va faire merci de s'ennuyer
on va faire la terrine de sanglier et si
on dans la tarn gigot de s'ennuyer
cuissots j'ai quelquefois monjeza ces
fameuses bombes ont quand même
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
commencer c'est très possible
olalala verre d'eau ou est ce qu'on a
dit on par abonné
on va voter c'est sa saisie bancaire
maintenant rouler on allait il m'arrive
souvent de de comparer une cuisine et
une entreprise le sens de la hiérarchie
très important le sens de la hiérarchie
le respect très important m'a dit à
julien c'est même l'un des axes
essentiels de ma thèse dans toutes les
cuisines que j'ai pu visiter
j'ai constaté un réel respect de la
décision du chef il impose le calme
le silence l'obéissance ces décisions
ont force de loi
je laisse un fils al walae et c'est vrai
un peu plus et on ne savait pas bien
pourquoi nous dis pas que c'est bien
d'avoir recommencé le sait bien on se
bat biéreau
l'asim n'était pas content avec ça mais
merde alors il est temps d'honorer ses
parts c'est la bonne note grecque et je
vais mettre à côté de l'armagnac pour
flamber tout sachez qu'elle sera cuit je
voudrais bien le mulet baiser canard là
vous y attend des poids légers mg de
phrase est solide et très jolie ces
derniers les gorges lui aurait coûté moi
si vous êtes sous je n'y peux rien les
oreilles à des cotons tiges il veut je
n'ai jamais dit ça l'offre déjà pelé
[ __ ] à en faire mais pas des ruines du
château [ __ ]
alors il nous faut tout d'abord de
l'armagnac toujours pareil après nous
faut du poireau et des carottes
non ce sont des pommes de terre ne
croyez vous pas vos merdes non ça ne va
pas de ces thèmes où c'était quoi aller
chanter on vous a pas écoutés encore
qu'est ce qui va nous ressortir sa
gueule mais je suis j'ai pas bougé
beaucoup et la nyanga et j'ai fait
attention et de la lie aux me suivent et
ben ça on n'a que ça à [ __ ]
ah c'est pas vrai ou quoi non il faut
recommencer
non on n'en est pas là c'est piqué place
dès samedi est quand même un haut et
sont en mer d'un cela refroidit horwath
loué le voulez vous show où le voulez
vous froid comme la fontaine des
miracles attention donnée parce qu'il
faut pas refaire allez c'est bon
maintenant 10 pour les pâtes et hop je
suis bien nature mais c'est patrice et
qui m'énerve c'est riche qui se redresse
de faire croire vous savez pas plus sur
ces derniers jours alors suivez
contracté 6
où vous comptez qu à nelson mahdia
julien pour autant que je puisse compter
je m'aperçois que je n'ai bu que 13 vert
et le chiffre 13 porte malheur chez nous
comme chez vous du reste c'est le 14e
qui vous ramènera chez vous absolument
pour autant que je puisse me lever on
reparlera de cuisine une autre fois en
attendant grasset la cuisine je vais me
lever plus de nous ont pas loupé
qu'est-ce qu'on a pas vu maïté aulas l'a
appuyé c'était bien joué qui comme
mourir n'aura pas désagréable du tout
nos biens ceci dit pour revenir sérieux
et il faut penser à la rochelle recèlent
bien au revoir à bientôt 1 et à votre
santé à tous ary chalus